dare
[音楽]
皆さんこんにちは8長谷川10
あのも可能はボブの生物生態系は9分屋久島に行って動物の生態の研究をしているん
ですけれども
今日はえーっ生物に見られる無駄と進化の永続性っていう話をします
新かというとダウンリズムが説明してるんですけれどもそれを超える話があるんだよっ
て話をしようと思います
ダービーが考えた進化の歯の原理っていうのはこういうものでその
ある種生物の集団人間なら人間の集団の中にですね
一答えあのと性変異によって増殖率が今までのものより高いものが現れると
そうするとそれは増殖率は高いからだんだん真ん中の済みタイマーなから日右の図
みたいにあの
だんだん増えていって最終的にはそれだけになってしまう
こうするて同色率が高いっていうことはその反響でたくさん子どもを残せるということ
なんで生き延びやすいとか
子供をたくさん同じ資源でも子供たくさんの干せるような効率が高いということで
結局たんケーキな常食率の高いほうが答え郡内に広がるって言うのが生存競争
ダーウィンなった生存競争
の解釈です進化するものの条件というのは3つあってですね一つは性質が伝わっていく
ということですこれがいいでんって呼ばれています
でしかもその遺伝するときにその性質があの
ずーっと同じじゃなくて少しずつ変わっていくこれを兵と呼んでいます
でこの2つが揃っているものがあると進化して新刊怒ってさらにその3番目の条件とし
て変異したものの間に単位時間当たりの増殖率が違うものがある
というのをこれを選択と呼んでいてこの三つがそろうとあの
勝手に自動的にその環境に一番合った競走能力の高いものが進化していきます
だからダーウィンは生物がそのいろんなところでうまく生きているのは a 神様
なんかなくてもこの3つの原理せず
ねできるよということで初めてその新敵を進化を科学的に説明することに成功したわけ
でこういう条件を満たすものなら何でも進化します
で写本とか茶の湯のお点前の進化の発表というのは神眼科医であったりしてまして年
カーブでそういうものを取り扱えるわけですね
ところがですねありというものの巣の中にはずっと働かないものが多くいるんですね
あるいはこういうふうに働きもんだとして有名ですが
実際に測ってみるとですねこれは門歩子蟻っていうのエソグラムって言って行動の記録
ですけど3つの abc って3つの頃にを図っていて
いろんな行動割をやるわけですけどその
何百回も見た家に何パーセントが労働で何パーセントかそうじゃなかったかっていうの
見ると
結局止まって何もしてないとか
巣の中をブラブラ動いているだけあるいは自分の体を清掃していた他の5体も役に何も
立たないみたいな労働者ない行動
度の試みでもだいたい6割ぐらいや7割ぐらいあっています
ある瞬間には7割が働かないんですね
なんでこうでしかもそのずーっと見ていてもやっぱり全然働かないアリっていうのがに
3割はいる
なんで働かないのかっていうそのハウ
どのようにして働かないアリが現れるのかというふうに反応閾値モデルというモデルが
考えられちょっと難しい言葉ですけど仕事を始める刺激が右の図みたいにですね
仕事の刺激がある程度の大きさがあると仕事を始めてそれ以上の大きさだったらいつも
仕事をするというのは生きちっこいの生き血反応って呼ぶんですけどあのこういう刺激
に対するは労働の生き血をありが持っていてそれが答えによって
ばらついているという時にその位置が低いグループは働きやすいのでそういう奴はいつ
も働くたつまりキレイ好きとそうでない人がいるとキレイ好きばかりいつも掃除して
いること抹茶ですね部屋汚れできたときも汚い人はけっ汚いのは平均1我慢できます
けどキレイ好きな人頑張って来ないでそうです
また汚れるときたがきれい付けないとかそういうするわけですね
でいつも働いている答えと働かないボタンが自動的に表れてしまうというわけ
あの位置が一曲てよく働くアクティブな答えと駅値が高くてほとんど働かないに
アクティブな答えをそれぞれを取り出してもやっぱり下の図のように2の版ばらつきと
いうのはできるのでやっぱりそれぞれの中でのアクティブなものと員約底の方に分かれ
てしまう
こういうのパレートの法則がに8の法則って言って会社のあの利益の8割は2割の人に
よって
束切らされているという話ですね
で誠氏らかにありはそうなんだって言われてるんですけど実際調べてみたらどこにも
そんなデータはないのでやってみたと北海道に普通にいる子は苦しかりってこれがそう
ですけどあのありを使ってこのようにそのありにあの
ペンキを塗ってですねこの個体ごとに全部
式部
5ができるようにしておいて働き度合いを調べました
で
2年かけて夏のコロニーで1ヶ月間行動を観察して全部で72回一匹について行動を
観察してそのうち何パーセントがその他のコロニーの利益に他のコロニーの答えの利益
につながるような労働で何パーセントはそうじゃなかったかというのを調べていました
左側の一番下
の頭の左側のグラフを見てもらうと分かりますけれどもあの横軸がこれが労働の頻度
ですゼロから位置までで一番左足のゼロというのは全く働かなかった個体で右足の位置
はあの72回見た牛なぁ12回とも働いていたという答えで
コロニーの中に非常に大きなばらつきがあるということがわかります
どの試みでもそうです
で
1年目の実験では左側の半分の8枚のパネルがそうでその左がのグラフの黒の部分
要するに働いてなかった方から30匹鳥だしてその後また1カ月間同じように考えする
とどうなるかというのを見たんですけど上から3番目のグラフを見てもらうとわかり
ますが働かない
ものだけ取り出したのに
ずっと働き続けるようなもがちゃんと現れるんですね
逆に2年目には3つのコロニーでその同じことをやって今度はよく働く方から30匹
だけ取り出して新しい試みを作ったときにどうなるかを見てますけどやはりどの
コロニーでも全く働かないものが出てきちゃ
ですね
なからパレートの法則は本当だったということがあの
分かったわけです
でもちろんあの若いから働かないんだとかねあの卵をたくさん持ってるから働かないん
だっていうのはその他の数つもあるのですがそういうのはすべて
さっきのパターンを説明できないという事を証明してあるので how 働かないのか
に関してはやっぱり市のバラつきがあるからだということになります
次に問題なのは進化として問題なのは
じゃあ何でそんな一時的にその効率が触っちゃうようなシステムを彼らが持っているの
かということが問題です
それは我々は疲労も出るというモデルをこれは我々が自分で考えました
今まであのありんこだって動物だからその筋肉で動いてるんで
あの
働けば疲れるはずなんですけどありが疲れるなんてことを考えた人は誰もいなかったん
ですね
down in の原則から言えばコロニーの全体の生産性が高い方が競争に2がはず
ですから
全員が働いている方がいいに決まっています
今までの数学モデルでもありはそういうふうに働くだろうと言われていたんですが
実際やってみると一部の者が働かないわけですね
なんでこんなシステムが採用されているのかという話で筋肉を使うと必ずスカル柄れる
と作業効率が落ちて休まなければ全員がいっぺんに働いちゃうようなシステムっていう
のは長続きしないんじゃないかということを考えました
これはあの実際なりを疲れさせることはまあほぼ不可能なんで
コンピューターのシュミレーションで実験をしたんですがまぁこうコンピュータの上に
こういうます目の空間をつくってですね実際には我々2500末のマス目をつくりまし
たけどその a 5割をばらまくわけです
我々75匹のありをばらまきましたけどまぁありはその自分が閾値というものを持って
行ってですねこのあり
脂という閾値を持っています
形はある時間にあのタイムステップってで実感が進んでいくんですけど時間が進むと
どっかし4のコマのどっかに移動しますそこに仕事があると仕事が持っている刺激つと
自分の生き血を比べていきチアの仕事の刺激性能が自分の息つより大きければ仕事の主
振りをするちー酒でもしないというルールを作っています
こうやって実際の者の生き血をあのシミュレートしてるわけですねこの場合にの後の
仕事であるこのあるいはその後の仕事を処理しますが
市の仕事であっても仕事の処理はしません
ねこの時にそれでそのまま15匹のありの中の閾値が全員子という平均値で a
分散がないつまり全員がいっぺんに働いちゃうようなことが起こりやすい
グループと平均がボデー
ゼロから位置まで0から10までの間の正規分布になるようなバラつきを持たせた
グループでどう違うかというのを見ています
あと疲れを入れなきゃいけないのでその1回仕事を処理するとある程度の時間
何もできなくなるという形で仕事疲れというものを入れています
それでそういうシミュレーションをやったんですけれども
まずこれは横軸にその2500のマスの中にどれだけ仕事が現れるかという仕事の出現
率をいくつか入れてやっているのでそれを横軸にとって縦軸に実感あたりに処理された
仕事の量の差というものを
閾値のばらつきがない要するに誰も休まない
グループからあの誰かがいつも休んでるグループの値を引いてやってます
これ一番下のラインがゼロなので a 結局パラメーターのエリアで色が違うのが疲労
の違いですで全く疲れないっていう条件からその1回仕事をする
ちょっと50タイムステップ休まないといけないっていうところまで行っていて戦
タイムステップまで趣味でしょうやってます
でへ見れば分かるようにあのどんなパラメーターでもあってもそのみんなが働くほうが
プラスの値になってますよね
みんなが働くほうが効率がいいということですこれ予想された結果で確かに全員が働く
方が効率が良いわけです
しかしですねあのこの時に
ある時間に1個も仕事が処理されないとコロニーはそこで滅びてしまう非常に強い過程
を入れてシミュレーションをしてその頃兄の存続時間送られていますでアリのコロニー
にこういう仕事があるのかっていうとあるそれは卵を舐めるという仕事で白炒り実験さ
れ
てますがシロアリでもありでも誰もの周りにはたくさん働きアリが群がって舐めてるん
ですけどシロアリで店をに集っている者働きあるよとみ動いて30分ぐらいおくと卵が
全部上手腐ってしまうという結果が出ていますシロアリの唾液の中にはあの抗生物質が
入っていてた本が腐らないように
いつもそれを塗ってるって事もわかっています
おそらくありと同じでしょたのは死んじゃうってことは次のコロニーの世代が全滅し
合うということで柄ポロミントで致命的です
で
そういうそのあるタイムステップに仕事が処理されないと滅びちゃうって条件を入れて
今度はあのシミュレーションでコロニーが存続した時間をいつも休んでいる者がいる
システムからみんなが働くようなシステムの存続時間をひくという形で出してやると
このようにですね下のグラフを見
入ってもらえばわかるんですがどっかのパラメーターのところ
パラメータによって現れる場所は違うんですが
いつも休んでいる者がいるシステムのほうが長続きする時間のパラメータエリアトナー
生じます
なぜそうなるのかというのを説明しているのが上の図で
点線が変異があって休む奴がいる頃に
実践が変異があって休む奴はいないコロニーですがそうするとそのどっちも仕事が
どんどん増えていくとへ
賄いきれなくなって皆疲れ発で誰も仕事ができなくなって滅びちゃうんですけどその力
にちょっとだけ差が生じるんですね
この探したの三角形とんがった三角形の
その
休む者がいる方はな月時間として現れます
つまり変異がある知って安物が入るシステムのほうが長続きするわけですね
つまり疲れちゃって働けなくなっちゃった時に今まで休んでいて働いていなかって疲れ
ていなかった兄が仕事の刺激が大きくなってくると働き出すので
ピンチヒッターとして機能するということです
もし本当にそうだとするとですね左側の図を見てほしいんですけど
普段よく働く蟻が
ほとんどつかれて働けなくなったときに
普段働かないアリがよく働くようにな
普段働く蟻がよく働いている時には普段働かないアリは働いていないというのはこう
いうマイナスの関係が観察されるはずです
れシュミレーションですからデータを自由に飛び焦るので右側にシミュレーションの
ある1階のデータをプロットしてまーやの
上から仕事をよくやった上から10%をよく働くありやらなかった全然働かなかった
10%働かないアリとしてそれぞれの死後の処理した仕事数を縦軸横軸にプロットして
ますけどそうするとちゃんとこう
非常に緩やかですがマイナスの関係が出てきてこれは統計的
有意なのでこのようなあの仕事の交代が本当にシュミレーションの中で起こっていたと
いうことがわかります
で本当の頃にでもそういうことが起こっているのかというのを調べるために最初の実験
で調べたありの8つのコロミィのデータを使って上位10%と回働きどへの上位10%
と下位10%の間で仕事の間にどういう相関関係があったかというのをちょっと偏相関
という
特殊な方法を使ってやってますとこの黒のバーが8つのコロニーですけども8つの頃に
すべてでマイナスの相関関係が見られます
つまりさっきのような関係がどのコロニーにもあったことですねコロニーゴンパ府統計
的に有意なにコロニーしかないんですがこういう独立に撮ったデータをそのまとめて
いる
分析するメタ分析という方法があるのでそれを使ってやってみたのが一番右の緑色の
バーでやっぱりマイナスの変装感があってこれは統計的に有意です
なんか本物形でも働く蟻が休んでいる時働かないアリが働くということが起こっている
ということが示されました
結局ですねその
みんなが疲れて全員が働けない状態ができてしまうとその頃にとってたいへん大きな
ダメージがあるので
要するにあるいは短期的な後列性よりもコロニーが滅びないということを優先している
わけですね
で a
生物の歴史っていうものを考えると
こういうもので生物で36億年前にその地球上のどこかで生じてそれらいるーと進化を
繰り返してきたわけですけど今生き残っている生物っていうのはその36億年間1回も
滅びたことがない生き物だけなんですね
でこれ上がアンモナイトドーム階ですけどこれは禁煙だと言われてますがアンモナイト
は市息栖鯉あの構成を起こりましたが今滅びてしまって
その末裔であるあの
オウムガイが細々と生き登っています
これからしたも頭も同じようなもので
恐竜も一時期全盛期を誇りましたけどそいつらみんな滅びてしまっていなくなって
しまって
恐竜の時代から存在して馬鹿女は今でも生きています
で今いるものは今生きて
いないものの今はいい息子は当たり前なんですけど今いるものは今生きてる着物しかい
ないんで長期長期的に存続することにセレクションがかかってないはずがないんですよ
ね
だってあの長期的な存続にセンターがかかってなかったキムは滅びてしまうからです
ラミーの進化論では一つの生物終盤の中で複数のタイプの間で増殖率は高いほうが増え
ていくよって話をしてますがその効率がどれだけ良くなったとしてもそれがずっと滅び
ない
多忙化についてはダメに妻何も言えないわけです
しかし現実の生物っていうのは一種類だけで生きてるわけじゃないね
群衆って言ってこうこの緑の丸11種類の生物だと思っていただければいいですけど
いろんな生物が
文集の中にいてその生物同士いろいろな関係を持っていろんな強さでもって a
文集として生きています
群衆っていうのをですね群衆の中の生物関係の総体として捉えるとですねうん州内の
関係っていうのは答えが死んで入れ替わっても同氏の性質は似ているのでその関係は
答えが入れ替わっても続きますつまり遺伝があるわけですね
で生物は徐々に進化していくのでその生物間の関係っていうのは少しずつ変化します
だから兵があるわけですね
だからあの最初に入った遺伝と変異があるので群衆というもの自体が進化するものです
ユニットとして考えることができます
しかし群衆はその普通の生物の意味でその群衆自体が増殖はしないし
離れた群衆と競争しないわけですね
でへ群衆は進化することが分かりましたけどじゃあ何に対して適用しているのかという
のはこれではわからん
で反応
文氏は増殖しませんからだー3リズムではその真価を記述理解することはできません
そこでこの話の肝ですがこういうことを考えました
この宇宙に存在する今あるすべてのものっていうのは生じて以来
崩壊したことがないものだけです
これを違うと言える人はいないですね生物も同じです36年前に生じて以来滅びなかっ
た者だけが今います
これがこれを永続性原理と我々呼んでいます
つまりいくら効率が高くても滅びたら終わりです
ということは群衆が進化するものだとしたら文集内の関係がその長続きするような形に
なった時のみに生き残ることができるわけです
群衆の中の生物関係の温州を滅ぼすように進化した場合その文章は滅びてしまいます
から
生物がいなくなってしまいますね
つまり文集内の関係が永続性を高めるように群衆はて灸をしていてつまり異なる群衆と
いうのはどれだけ長続きできるかということに対して競争していてそれに対して適用
すると考えることができます
このあの長続きの度合いというのを何らかの形で定量化して a
一つの適応度として考えれば群衆の進化というものを記述
理解可能になります温州の適用というものですね
でこれからそれをやっていこうと思っているんですが
れ結局働かないアリっていうのは短期的な効率を犠牲にしてもコロニーの長期的存続を
可能にしてするように進化していると考えられます
他にベッド heading と言って砂漠に住む株と襟の親なんかがそのたまごが何
回濡れたら子供になるかっていうのねすごくばらつきを持たせてる現象が知られている
んですがこれもちょっとだけ雨が降ったときに一斉に子供が帰ってしまうと水たまりが
干上がって全滅しちゃういうことを防ぐためにこうなっている
考えられていてそのベッド heading と呼んでいるんですが
結局そういう例のところでそのそれはその短期的な蔵書効率を高めるんだというだー水
が考えると
ダーウィニズムには矛盾してますけれども存続が最優先だと考える永続性原理には矛盾
してません
まぁ結局進化というのはそのダウンリズムというのは確かにその通りの新刊起こってい
ますがその上に永続性原理というものがあって永続性原理
ダーウィンリズムに矛盾しても永続性原理には無住しない進化はありえますが
永続性原理に矛盾する進化を起こした場合群衆を滅びてしまうのでいなくなるので結局
永続性原理というのはダウンジェフの進化におけるダウンロードの上位のパラダです
だから結局その何があっても永続性原理に矛盾する進化を置きないですねただここの
生物が進化していくのはダウンリズムに従っているわけです
まぁ僕も定年まであと10年になったんで
最後の siri 花としてこれを理論的です実験的に証明するということをやって
進化論の話の世界を書き換えようと思っているんですがまぁ
そういうことを考えていますながらあの一緒にそういうことをやりたいと思う方が
いらっしゃったらうちの研究室に進学するということを考えていただいても結構です
これで確か最後のスライダーじゃないなもう一つだったら
で追われるものです
[拍手]